hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear
now i think i'm probably speaking for
most horror nerds like me
when i say
that there are really very few things in
life uh that are as gratifying or as
joy-inducing
uh as stumbling across a movie pretty
much randomly that you'd never really
heard of before and finding out that
it's actually one of the most
entertaining things that you've seen in
a very very long time and that's pretty
much exactly what happened with today's
movie which is called bloody hell and it
came out in 2020 originally i think it
was one of those things that you know
kind of premiered at festivals and stuff
like that and then didn't get a wider
release until early 2021 as far as i
could determine
now this movie i actually first just saw
it it popped up on shutter probably like
a month ago something like that and it
uh subsequently earned that oh so
rarefied five skull rating which like i
said you don't really see that much on
there uh and it's usually like older
films that get it so that kind of like
perked my interest right away
now as i normally do and i've said this
on many of the shows before
i didn't read any further than the one
sentence synopsis which was on shutter
now in this case the one
sentence synopsis for bloody hell was
and this is a direct quote a man with a
mysterious past flees the country to
escape his own personal hell only to
arrive somewhere much much much worse
and that's it yeah that doesn't even
like begin to contain uh but yeah so
so i just read that and i was like five
skull is okay i'm on board so i hit play
on that sucker and then went on to soak
in the awesomeness bloody hell was
actually written by robert benjamin uh
amazingly in his screenwriting debut and
directed by an australian filmmaker
named aleister grierson now he only has
like a couple of films uh it appears
under his belt at this point probably
the best known of those being uh for
this 2011 film it was like a 3d like
cave diving drama called sanctum i think
it was produced by james cameron or
james cameron had something to do with
it but i have to say with both of these
guys like don't let this lack of
previous credits fool you because this
movie just has wit style and hilarity
for days and features some really really
fantastic like really gruesome practical
effects and some really like creative
kills for to get kind of like maybe like
an idea of the ballpark of this movie
imagine if the movie hostile
was directed by sam raimi and also had
kind of like some fight club like stuff
in there as well and you're kind of like
getting into let's kind of like the area
that we're talking about so bloody hell
is an action horror comedy i guess i
would call it now it was shot in
australia but it's actually set in both
boise idaho and helsinki finland uh this
works because most of it is shot indoors
so it doesn't really matter you don't
really see like a lot of the outside so
you don't really like think like hey
that's australia or anything like that
now i will say that although the script
is amazing it's very tight it's just
like laugh out loud funny in places the
real star of the show here is the lead
actor ben o'toole now he's an australian
actor and uh just flawlessly playing an
american i didn't even realize he was
australian like why i was watching this
and his charisma is just like off the
charts and he has just like impeccable
comic timing uh the guy gives off some
real kind of like robert downey jr vibes
like in the best possible way like you
know what i mean like a tony stark kind
of thing but not quite that sarcastic
but similar kind of along those lines uh
this guy really needs more roles and
bigger roles like immediately like
yesterday you know what i mean like this
guy's great uh other than this movie i
think he's done some australian tv and
he had some kind of smaller roles in
hacksaw ridge like from 2016 and a movie
called 12 strong and i knew that i had
recognized him from somewhere and
the place i recognized him from is
actually the only other lead role that
i've ever seen him in which was actually
a movie called necrotronic from 2018
which was like another australian kind
of horror comedy which i think i also
saw on shutter and that's also great
it's not as good as this one but it's
also pretty good and uh he's in that as
well like as a lead role and as far as i
know
that movie and this one are the only
ones that he's had a lead role in so far
and hopefully that changes down the line
because like i said he's great now in my
opinion bloody hell is much better gone
into without any knowledge of what it's
about or where it's going i mean i
generally find that's true of most
movies but in this one uh like
particularly
so if you're gonna
watch any further uh either go watch the
movie and then come back or continue on
at your own peril because i'm assuming
that you don't care i'm not gonna spoil
what happens at the ending but i will be
talking about some plot points that you
might not want to know in advance so
this is your last warning if you want to
watch it without knowing anything about
it then please amped gray and then come
back later okay so now that all those
people are gone or
you know or don't care past this point
so ben o'toole uh plays a guy named rex
now he's a military veteran they don't
go too much into his backstory but you
can kind of like figure it out like from
context clues or whatever
now at the beginning he kind of
apparently has this crush slash
flirtation thing
going on with this woman named maddie
who's played by a woman named ashley
lawback now she works at a bank credit
union type situation
so one day uh rex is visiting maddie at
her teller window like i guess like
trying to ask for a date or whatever and
while that's happening a group of four
armed guys wearing masks like bust into
the bank and start doing like a very
violent robbery i mean like they bust in
and like shoot somebody right away and
like make everybody get down and stuff
like that now rex with the help of his
previous military training and it should
be said also his sort of wisecracking
conscience who actually manifests
throughout the movie as another version
of himself that he has like discussions
with he knows that it's not there he's
not like crazy but that's how the movie
conveys that he's like talking to
himself and like figuring stuff out in
his head is there's another version of
him that's like more sarcastic and uh
you know and it helps him like kind of
like come to decisions about things and
i really really like that aspect of the
movie because you're able to like kind
of get inside
his head with that like in a really
creative way without having to do like a
voiceover or something like that it's
like a really stylish way of doing it so
uh so he's able to actually get the drop
on the criminals and ends up pretty much
like wasting them
uh saving pretty much all the employees
and the customers at the bank although
his vigilante tactics do result in one
innocent person getting killed
now because of this rex gets arrested
and the d.a i guess like reckless
endangerment or something like that the
d.a offers him a deal they're like look
you can either serve eight years in
prison and then just like walk away
scot-free or you can take it take your
chances with like a jury trial or
whatever and risk getting 20 years which
is like the minimum sentence so he says
well i'll just take the eight
so he ends up like going to prison and
serving his time they don't really go a
lot into that in the movie so because
it's not like hugely important now after
he gets out of prison he has to deal
with being something of a celebrity i
mean footage of the heroics that he
pulled at the bank went viral
and most people kind of think he's a
badass like on par with like john wick
because he does do like some kind of
john wick [ __ ] there are still like some
people who kind of blame him for getting
that one innocent woman killed so
there's kind of like you know some
people are just like [ __ ] with him
and stuff and everywhere he goes he's
just getting photographed and all that
kind of crap adding to all this is the
fact that he's still like a little bit
bummed out heartbroken i guess like that
by the fact that maddie who was you know
the woman who had a crush on whose life
he actually saved on that particular day
only visited him in prison once and that
was to tell him hey i never want to see
you again because i don't know you well
enough and i don't like it i don't want
to have to feel obligated to like come
here and see you
just because i feel bad so it was like
it was pretty harsh i'm just saying that
she but she laid down some like truth or
whatever so but he was like kind of
bummed out about that so he's like well
hey i saved your life you know what i
mean so there's that whole thing
so to get away from all the kind of
media hoopla and you know the bad
memories he has surrounding maddie he
decides he's going to leave the country
for a while now he decides on finland
simply because when he was in his jail
cell still
and he was like thinking about getting
out he's like uh so he shot some spit
balls like at a map on the wall and like
three of them inexplicably landed in
finland uh as though his fate had
already been decided and he's like okay
well i guess that doesn't usually happen
so finland it is now upon arriving in
finland he is immediately like in the
airport we're talking uh he gets
immediately eyeballed by this very
creepy like older finnish couple
and they're talking about him but
obviously they're speaking finnish and
he doesn't know what they're saying but
a friendly bystander kind of comes by
and says hey those two said that they
were planning to get you so he kind of
just thinks oh well maybe they just
recognize me like from the news or
something like that so he just like
ignores them but then when he goes
outside the airport to get a cab the
driver inside there like gasses him and
then some indeterminate amount of time
later
rex finds himself hanging from like a
ceiling beam in this dark basement with
one of his legs missing from the knee
down so from there
rex and his conscience slash alter ego
have to figure out a way to get out of
this predicament before it gets any
worse than it already is
uh see it turns out that rex has
actually been abducted by this very
freaky finnish family
who
it ends up like have this really
grotesque sun
with let's call them some very specific
dietary requirements okay
so
uh from this point like i said rex is
gonna have to use like his intelligence
his military training and he does get
some help from the seemingly normal
daughter of the family uh to basically
like keep from being portioned off as
snacks uh just piece by piece so as i
mentioned this movie was an absolute
riot i mean it was just like i mean it's
a dark comedy for sure like it's not you
know what i mean but it's just i don't
know it was just like really just
exuberantly fun
really fast-paced i mean it's not very
long it's only like 90 minutes it had a
lot of really good like well-executed
black humor some great gore set pieces a
lot of it having to do with like you
know body parts getting cut off and like
you know real gory [ __ ] like that i had
a great [ __ ] musical score i have to
like bring that up a little bit too i
mean the interactions between rex and
his you know snarkier conscience who was
you know obviously the same actor i was
just like in stitches like a lot of
their interactions are like super funny
and i also really liked the very very
amusing chemistry between
rex and the weird family's daughter
her name was uh alia and she's actually
played by a woman named meg frazier and
this is her first movie so she did
[ __ ] great so this movie is just like
i said it's very i don't want to go too
much in the direction of saying it's
like sam raimi-ish it is kind of like
that but it's not like quite as wacky or
quite as over-the-top but it does have
this really stylishly shot kind of thing
that evokes like sam raimi a little bit
but it's kind of like its own thing um
and it also has like a lot of really
really good like effective tension like
it's not scary scary but it does like
have a lot of tension in it uh it is
like expertly paced
and it has also a lot of like really
clever kind of inside jokes and a lot of
um movie references which are really
good they're kind they're subtle like
sometimes but they're really like well
done and some of them are actually like
pretty obscure and like i was just kind
of like wait did they just refer oh yeah
okay i see what you did there that's
like pretty awesome so i mean it was
just and the performance performances
it's just it was just so so good like
all the performances are good everybody
in it is good it was just fantastic it's
just like a hell of a good time uh and
just watching it just made me giddy with
happiness and i just love what that when
that happens because it was a movie that
i hadn't really you know seen anything
about i hadn't really heard of it before
like i hadn't seen any buzz about it or
anything and i just kind of saw it
because
there it was on shutter and it had five
skulls and i was just kind of like oh
you know ones with five skulls because
like i said people that um rate the
movies on shutter they're all like
horror nerds like mace they're like
usually super super picky and you don't
usually see stuff especially newer
movies that have five skulls so that
like got my interest right away and this
was absolutely worth it i just had a
[ __ ] blast with this movie it's so so
fun so if you're really really into
horror comedies particularly like very
very dark comedies that have like a lot
of gore uh then you will probably really
really love this it's just a fun movie
in general and i just had a great time
watching it so if you have shutter
please check it out it's definitely
definitely worth it so that'll do it for
this flickers of fear i will see you
guys again on the next one bye